[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous
bienvenue dans votre 78 nous sommes le
mercredi 17 janvier voici le programme
de ce soir le département va peut-être
de nouveau revêtir son manteau blanc
cette nuit Météo France place les
Yvelines en vigilance orange neige
verglas jusqu'à demain matin ce qui
pourrait perturber vos conditions de
circulation on fait le point en début
d'émission c'est la galère depuis le
début du mois de janvier dans la vallée
de Chevreuse les bus du réseau Transdev
ne circulent plus faute de chauffeur
pour palier ce manque certains élus sont
obligés de faire le taxi pour les
écoliers il y a 100 ans le père de la
Tour effffel s'est éteint pour lui
rendre hommage la ville de poissie
consacre une exposition à Gustave eel au
sein de la la maison de fer il fallait
le faire et puis comme d'habitude
l'invité du 78 en 2è partie d'émission
tout au long du mois de janvier les
maires de Saint-Quentin en Eveline
viennent présenter les grands projets de
l'année 2024 dans leur commune ce soir
François Morton le maire de Guill encour
sera avec nous voilà le programme de ce
soir mais tout de suite on retrouve
Grégory canalé qui se trouve au niveau
de la 12 entre saint-ciire l'école et
FONTEN le Fleury je le disais à
l'instant les Yvelines sont en vigilance
orange neige vergla quelles sont les
dernières prévisions
Grégory alors pour le moment Mathilde
bonsoir pas de neige on parle ici plutôt
d'une fine pluie qui tombe actuellement
sur saint-ciè l'école mais la situation
vous l'avez dit pourrait évoluer dans
les prochaines heures puisque le
département des ivelines comme le reste
de l'Île-de-France est placé ce soir en
vigilance orange à la neige et au
verglace c'est une vigilance qui court
jusqu'à au moins demain matin jeudi dans
le milieu de la matinée en attendant
donc cette nuit Météo France vous le
disiez prévoit des des chutes de neige
on parle de 3 à 5 cm qui pourrai tomber
dans le département c'est tel cas il y a
une semaine he par exemple on est sur
des conditions similaires dans la pointe
sud des ivelines on parle même de
conditions moindr avec 1 à 3 cm qui
pourrait tomber localement donc vous
l'avez compris c'est pas encore un un
gros épisode de neige comme on avait pu
l'observer en 2018 où l' était tombé
jusqu'à 15 cm de neige en Île-de-France
côté circuit ulation c'est l'autoroute à
12 qui est derrière moi alors pour une
heure de pointe pour le moment vous le
voyez ça roule plutôt bien en ce
mercredi soir mais la situation pourrait
se dégrader hein si chute de neige
importante il y a la préfecture de la
région Île-de-France conseille au dans
dans le plus grand possible de limiter
ses déplacements de rentrer également à
son domicile avant 19h si vous devez
prendre la route tout de même n'hésitez
pas à emporter à bord une couverture des
vivres dans le cas où vous vous
retrouveriez bloqué sur la route de
nouvelles mesures de restriction pourrai
être prises si jamais la situation
venait à se dégrader la nuit dernière
par exemple l'interdiction de la
circulation des poids lourds sur les
grands axes de la région ainsi que
l'interdiction pour tous les
automobilistes de doublet avaient été
prise par la préfecture de région et la
nationale 118 pourrait se retrouver
fermé si c'est nécessaire mais ce n'est
pas d'actualité à l'heure où je vous
parle
bien merci beaucoup Grégory canalé merci
également à Julien l roi au moyens
techniques et soyez prudent sur la route
lors de votre retour et on continue de
parler de la neige et du verglas dans
les informations du jour avec Gabriel
Gontier c'est tout de
[Musique]
suite Gabriel la neige et le varglass
sont attendu dans les ivelines cette
nuit comment le département se
prépare-t-il et bien Mathilde la préf
fecture des ivelines a enclenché la
vigilance orange neigeeverglat depuis
hier soir 22h et jusque demain 10h alors
20 saleleuses et des neigeuses seront
déployés dans la soirée des axes
vallonnais comme la N 118 pourrai être
amené à fermer on fait un point sur la
situation avec Richard del leepierre en
charge des transports et des mobilités
dans les ivelines on est évidemment
parfaitement préparé équipé pour traiter
nos voiries en éger on est toujours plus
inquiet pour le verglas parce que c'est
beaucoup plus dangereux donc là on n'a
pas de pas de sujet on sait que la neige
va arriver on ne sait pas en quelle
quantité elle va tomber les alertes
météo sont pas fait pour qu'on ne s'en
servent pas donc tous ceux qui n'ont pas
besoin de prendre leur voiture demain
sont évidemment invités à ne pas la
prendre les routes sont quand même
compliquées à circuler même si les voies
sont traitées il y aura de la neige il y
aura sans doute de la neige en quantité
important alors si vous devez quand même
vous déplacer privilégier les transports
en commun et sachez que les RER A et B
circuleront à blanc toute la nuit pour
éviter le gel sur le réseau fer et pour
rester informé sur les opérations en
cours l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin
en Yveline a mis en place le service
hivernal alerte SMS et surtout soyez
prudent dans vos déplacements en ce
début d'année 2024 des nouvelles
communes intègrent le dispositif
quartier prioritaire de la ville oui et
de nouveau quartier intègre ce
dispositif les acacia aquanière et larve
au clés sous-bois de leur côté les
petits prês à hlencour et vieux pays à
Sartrouville n'en font plus partie
instauré en 2015 ce dispositif vise à
réduire les écarts de développement de
certaines villes il améliore l'accès à
l'emploi la culture la réussite scolaire
en 2023 dans les ivelines 4 millions
d'euros avaient été investis pour
rénover des infrastructures et plus de
700 jeunes avaient été accompagnés
retard et suppression voilà le quotidien
des voyageurs qui empreuntent le tramé
trèss T13 oui et depuis presque 2
semaines c'est comme ça la circulation
du T13 est perturbée et ce au moins
jusqu'à fin février de 21h à minuit tout
le long de la ligne c'est-à-dire de
Saint-Germain en lait à saint-sire pour
le weekend le trafic reste habituel ces
dérèglements ils sont d à des travaux de
prolongement des chemins de fer
l'objectif relié à cher à la ville de
Saint-Germain en lait en passant par
poissie des bus de substitution sont mis
en place en revanche vous l'imaginez
Mathilde la vigilance orange
neigeverglas risque d'ajouter des
dérèglements ces prochaines heures un
mot de sport à présent Gabriel le Stade
Français va bientôt s'installer dans les
ivelines oui le camp des Loges de
Saint-Germain en la va passer du bleu au
rose et pour cause le club de rugby
parisien devrait s'y installer le site
était libre depuis le départ du PSG à
poissie c'est le club parisien
actuellement 3e du Top 14 qui va prendre
possession des lieux d'après nos
confrères du Parisien les travaux
devraient bientôt commencer sur le site
l'installation est prévue cet été pour
ce que l'on surnomme les soldas roses on
poursuit avec du sport une mauvaise
nouvelle en tennis oui Mathilde il n'y a
plus d'ivelinois dans le tableau final
de l'Open d'Australie Caroline Garcia
originaire de Saint-Germain en la a été
éliminé au 2è tour du tournoi du grand
schlem une défaite en 27 face à la
Polonaise Magdalena fraèche 64 76 grosse
déception pour la française 19e au
classement WTA qui s'incline contre la
69e joueuse mondiale et on termine avec
une actu cinéma Gabriel oui alors
aujourd'hui est sorti dans les salles le
film comme un prince parmi les acteurs
Ahmed Sila ou encore Jonathan Cohen le
film mais en scène un boxeur qui rêve de
devenir champion olympique avant de se
blesser au cours d'une bagarre il va
alors devoir effectuer plusieurs heures
de travaux d'intérêt général et si je
vous en parle Mathilde c'est qu'une
partie des scènes du film ont été
tournées dans les ivelines plus
précisément au Murau on regarde un
extrait de la bande annonce on est très
attendu sur ces Jeux Olympiques les gars
j'attends de vous un comportement
irréprochable les
gars le mec il a porté plain on fait
quoi maintenant moi j'ai rien fait
moi c'est pas moi qui a fait c'est mon
pote qui a fait c'est lui qui avait le
fusil la gosse je vous jure je l'ai pas
touché de quoi vous me parlez la gosse
la gosse mais moi moi c'est BAGAR moi
c'est bagarre les tiges c'est pas les
vacances t les il va être avec nous
pendant quelques mois là au jardin il a
joué au con et il a perdu voilà bah nous
on a rien fait on est là gros alors
parmi les lieux reconnaissables dans le
film le club de boxe du BAM l'héritage
ou encore le gymnase Pierre de Coubertin
tourneré au Mureau était une volonté du
réalisateur qui a grandi dans la commune
le film il s'inscrit dans la volonté de
la Ville d'accueillir davantage de
tournages c'est un film que j'irais bien
voir au cinéma et ben vous pouvez y
aller dès ce soir merci beaucoup Gabriel
Gontier pour toutes ces informations et
comme d'habitude si vous aussi vous avez
une actualité une image ou une
information qui vous a marqué près de
chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous la
partager sur les réseaux sociaux en
utilisant le #t 7
news depuis le 1er janvier les bus qui
desservent la vallée de Chevreuse ne
circulent plus en cause un changement
d'opérateur et un manque de chauffeur
interpellé par les élus du territoire la
présidente d'Île-de-France mobilité
Valérie pcrè a tapé du point sur la
table et promet un retour à la normale
d'ici la fin de la semaine c'est le
reportage de Clara de Frutos c'est bon
pour vous vous avez pas besoin vous
emmène non non ça va aller presque tous
les jours depuis une semaine police
municipale et élus sont présents à la
sortie du collège Pierre de Coubertin de
Chevreuse après plusieurs jours de
perturbation sur le réseau des bus
Transdev tout n'est pas encore revenu à
la normale là aujourd'hui il nous manque
la ligne 3917 sur le le parking du
collège c'est-à-dire la ligne qui permet
de ramener les enfants à la gare de
Saint-Rémi les chevreuses c'est une
ligne qui est qui est vraiment
structurante pour le territoire et qui
manifestement a oublié de passer par le
collège euh à 4h15 donc l'heure à
laquelle finissent les enfants
aujourd'hui un bus qui ne passe pas et
ce sont plusieurs élèves qui sont sur le
carreau ce jour-là moi par exemple
j'habite à courcell j'habite super loin
bah faut que je prne je marche jusqu'à
la gare je prenne le herur pour rentrer
chez moi je mets tout le temps 20 ans à
rentrer chez moi du coupf c'est long
quoi là on va retourner à pied hein une
situation qui dure depuis le 1er janvier
date à laquelle les lignes de bus en
Vallée de Chevreuse ont changé
d'opérateur anciennement assuré par la
SAVAC c'est maintenant Transdev Sud
Eveline qui a repris le trafic dans
cette zone un changement qui serait à
l'origine des nombreuses difficultés en
raison du manque de conducteur depuis le
1er janvier on a vu une très forte
dégradation du service on demande à ce
que IDFM prenne toute disposition pour
garantir la continuité de service public
auprès de l'opérateur transdef
interpellé par les élus du territoire
Valérie pcres président d'î de France
mobilité n'a pas tardé à réagir la
situation dans la vallée de Chevreuse
n'est pas acceptable et nous suivons de
très près la situation des solutions
enfin été trouvées à court terme la
qualité de service la régularité la
ponctualité l'information voyageurs sont
au cœur de nos préoccupations il est
primordial que les opérateurs puissent
tenir ses engagements pris dans le
contrat à l'issue d'une réunion avec les
élus Transdev s'est engagé à assurer 100
% des lignes scolaires dès la semaine du
15 janvier dans son communiqué
l'opérateur affirme qu'une vingtaine de
conducteurs supplémentaires devrai être
recrutés et affectés le plus rapidement
possible sur le réseau si les
engagements ne sont pas tenus île- de
France mobilité demandera la mise en
place d'une sous-traitance pour assurer
le
service Noël est passé et il est grand
temps de jeter son sapin mais pas
n'importe où plusieurs parcs à sapin ont
été mis en place dans votre commune du
côté de maison Lafite la mairie propose
même aux habitants une collecte original
ce sont les chevaux qui ramassent vos
sapins une initiative écologique pour
transformer ces c'est végéaux en
paillage le reportage de Julien Leroi
oui s un peu les reculement devant s'il
te
plaît ici là mets les deux trous rest il
doit y avoir une marque faut mettre la
marque ça fait au 5è ouais et ça sera le
bon réglage ouais on va rgler Arny bien
attaché avant le grand départ comme
chaque année depuis 2018 Johann et ses
équipes se mettent en celle pour la
collecte des sapins de Noël des
habitants de maison Lafite avec leur
entreprise des calèges de versaill il
réalise l'opération à cheval en moins
d'une semaine au pied des domiciles 15 à
20 km sont parcourus chaque jour pour 5
he à travers les rue allez F c'est
bien nous sommes trois paratelages donc
une personne qui mène les chevaux he
donc le cocher qui je te disait tout à
l'heure et bien il y a une rotation
puisque nous sommes tous cochés et donc
à la fois riper donc les gens qui
chargent les qui chargent les sapins et
quelqu'un un petit peu dans la ben aussi
parce que les sapins étant très
volumineux nous sommes obligés un petit
peu de les ranger et de les tasser pour
pouvoir en mettre un nombre conséquent
rentabiliser un petit peu les tournées
et justement pas devoir allonger les
temps de travail des chevaux et tout ça
voilà une initiative originale et
écologique permettant d'éviter
l'utilisation d'un camion pour le
dernier jour de ramassage ce mardi 16
janvier deux calèches et quatre chevaux
de trait sont sollicités de Ras
Percheron et cob normand ces animaux
sont sélectionnés pour leur élégance et
leur endurance un atout sympathie
attisant enthousiasme de la population
c'est un signe marqueur pour tous les
habitants il il repère les calèches
cette année on les a bien décorés donc
on les voit de loin on entend le bruit
des
sabots les les voitures qui sont
derrière qui sont un peu bloqué
finalement ne roussepète pas de trop
hein ça fait ça fait partie du folklore
au pays du cheval c'est quand même la
moindre des choses c'est trop chouette
non c'est une super belle belle action
merci à la ville de d'instaurer ça 2500
sapins naturels auront été ramassés lors
de ces 5 jours de collecte HPO mobile
prochaine étape la transformation des
végétaux en broyas utilisés comme
dsherban pour la commune nouveauté cette
année les mensoniens pourront aussi en
récupérer gratuitement pour leur jardin
rendez-vous près du Palais Omnisport
pierre du prè jusqu'au 21 janvier
prochain pour en
profiter et on rappelle donc qu'il ne
faut pas jeter son sapin n'importe où se
débarrasser de son sapin dans la rue ou
au pied de son immeuble peut vous valoir
une amende de 135 € direction poissi à
présent dans votre 78 à l'occasion du
100e anniversaire de la mort de Gustave
Effel la maison de fer rend hommage au
père de la tour effffel c'est le
reportage de Gabriel Gontier rendre
hommage à celui sans qui la maison de
fer n'aurait peut-être jamais exister
pour le centenaire de la mort de Gustave
Effel la maison de fer de poissie
célèbre sa mémoire dans une installation
spécialement conçue pour l'occasion il
s'agit d'une installation qui a ouvert
ses portes ici le 13 décembre à la
Maison de fer donc on a choisi de rendre
hommage à Gustave Eiffel pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord parce que ça la maison
de fer a longtemps été appelée la maison
Effel peut-être à tort puisqu'on la doit
plutôt à l'architecte belge Joseph danli
mais on a souhaité rendre hommage à
Gustave Effel ici parce que les
techniques employé dans ces
constructions ces ponts ces ces tours et
et d'autres constructions qu'on connaît
rappelle le le mode de construction de
la maison de fer en kit avec donc du fer
une armature au programme de ces
quelques jours d'hommage un film
pédagogique retraçant l'histoire de
Gustave Eiffel et de ses œuvres à
l'image de la Dame de fer dont
l'architecture industrielle a inspiré la
maison de fer on se trouve dans une
maison qui est quand même le fleuron de
de la période industrielle c'est un
chef-dœuvre de cette période rendre
hommage à Gustav Effel ici c'est assez
naturel et pourtant il a fallu imaginer
une une installation qui soit pas
forcément une exposition de fond avec
énormément de documents mais plutôt
plutôt un clin d'œil plutôt une une
ouverture vers l'œuvre desffelles qui
qui ici trouve évidemment un écho très
pertinent 100 ans après la mort de
Gustav Eiffel la maison de fer reste
l'un des rares témoignages de son
influence dans les Yvelines
l'installation hommage est à découvrir
jusqu'au 31 janvier
2024 et c'est bientôt l'heure de
l'invité du 78 mais avant je vous
propose de jeter un coup d'œil à la
météo de
demain demain matin nous devrions avoir
un ciel voilé sur une grande partie des
Yvelines seul le secteur de rambouillé
devrait se couvrir de nuages au niveau
des températures tout le monde est logé
à la même enseigne il fera 0°gr sur
l'ensemble du département l'après-midi
la situation s'inverse le ciel devrait
se couvrir sur une lâche partie des
Yvelines sauf dans le secteur de
rambouillé et côté température il fera
en moyenne 3 à 2° et pour rappel les
Yvelines sont toujours placées par
météoance en vigilance orange neige
Vergl et demain nous fêterons la sainte
Prisca c'est l'heure à présent de
l'invité du
[Musique]
78 et ce soir l'invité du 78 c'est le
maire de Guill encour François Morton
bonsoir bonsoir madame bonne année 2024
mes meilleurs vœux bonne année également
à tous les aiguill en courtois et
lesiguill en courtoise alors tout
d'abord François Morton si onit un
retour rapidement sur l'année 2023
qu'est-ce que vous retenez de cette
année écoulée à gui encs alors on
retient à guui en cour comme ailleurs un
contexte international un peu compliqué
voilà parce que ça a forcément des
implications aussi sur nos habitants et
le rôle des élus c'est de maintenir une
situation apaisée après on a les
problématiques chroniques d'une ville
comme Guy encour autour du logement par
exemple hein qui est l'une des
préoccupations les plus importantes de
la ville de guancour et puis la
l'avancement d'un certain nombre de
chantiers importants je pense évidemment
à celui du métro et du quartier des
savoirs oui on va en parler dans dans
quelques instants une année compliquée
donc il a également eu les les émeutes
urbaines est-ce qu'il va avoir des
mesures des mises en place par rapport à
ça alors on a été particulièrement
touché comme d'autres villes comme la
plupart des villes de 50 an en Yveline
d'ailleurs et notamment en terme de de
tranquillité publique avec un
commissariat de police municipale qui a
été effectivement ch donc nous avons d
reloger pendant un certain temps et
c'est encore le cas notre police
municipale oui nous avons été impactés
nous allons continuer avec le plus grand
sérieux à traiter cette question de la
tranquillité publique au travers bien
évidemment des leviers qui sont les
nôtres la police municipale le système
de vidéo protection par exemple qui est
encore développé et puis en travaillant
évidemment et surtout avec l'État à
travers le dialogue aussi je suppose oui
évidemment avec présence dans les
quartiers permanentes et je pense
notamment à la présence des élus et je
pense que la présence des élus dans les
quartiers est absolument primordiale
donc est-ce qu'à cause de ce contexte
financier compliqué pour les
collectivités vous allez devoir
augmenter les impôts locaux cette année
alors non nous ne le ferons pas nous
n'augmenterons pas la part communale de
la taxe foncière qui est le seul levier
fiscal à notre disposition donc non ça
n'est pas le cas alors dans les projets
pour l'année 2024 il y a la
réhabilitation des écoles de l'uné
montriseau olidzer et Fromont qu'est-ce
qui est prévu concrètement alors on
accélère ces réhabilitations et
notamment réhabilitation énergétique on
entretient notre patrimoine pour vous
donner une idée ces deux groupes
scolaires puisqu'il s'agit de deux
groupes scolaires dans deux quartiers
différents c'est environ environ 6
million et demi d'euros hein pour la la
réhabilitation globale alors ce sont des
groupes scolaires un peu vieillissants
même s'il ne sont pas si vieux que ça
hein puisque la ville nouvelle n'est pas
une ville ancienne mais nous avons
besoin Besin d'aller encore plus loin et
encore plus vite pour des raisons qui
sont évidentes pour nos habitants hein
c'est celle évidemment de la crise
énergétique et donc quel est l'agenda
des travaux alors des études encore en
cours actuellement avec un début de
travaux durant l'année 2024 toujours
concernant les travaux dans la commune
en ce moment se déroul ceux de la ligne
18 du Grand Paris Express où est-ce que
ça en est alors le tunnelier hein
puisque nous avons besoin d'un tunnelier
pour construire un tunnel pour creuser
un tunnel il est en cours de montage une
partie est déjà arrivée donc déjà des
travaux ont eu lieu notamment pour
accueillir la la gare hein une grande
capsule de 15 m de profondeur a déjà été
creusé euh j'ai j'ai eu la chance de
pouvoir voir ce chantier récemment et
puis euh dans la deuxème partie de
l'année 2024 le début alors la fin du
montage du tunnelier le montage d'un
tunnelier pour vous donner une idée ça
ça met 6 mois voilà simplement pour
monter l'engin voilà en pièce détachée
qui arrive en pièce détaché et ensuite
il va pouvoir commencer son travail en
allant vers versaill dimanche dernier il
y a eu une manifestation contre la ligne
18 il dénonce notamment
l'artificialisation des terres agricoles
et les nuisances sonores qu'en est-il à
Guy encours comment est-ce que se
positionnent les habitants euh alors
j'ai cru comprendre not notamment au
travers de la presse que les les
organisateurs regrettaient le manque de
mobilisation c'est vrai que sur H en
cours particulièrement nous sommes assez
peu impactés puisque je vous le rappelle
que sur en cours l'ensemble du tracé est
souterrain donc il y a pas d'impact sur
ces terres agricoles c'est plutôt en
amont et encore une fois je peux
comprendre le combat de de ceux qui qui
souhaitent alerter mais sur gu en
courour on est assez peu impacté et
c'est grâce à mes prédécesseurs qui dès
le départ avaient fixer effectivement le
cadre de cette ligne 18 alors autre
grand projet pour la commune depuis
plusieurs années déjà le quartier des
savoirs cette année le projet va passer
en phase de concertation concernant les
équipements publics et les mobilités
notamment alors une nouvelle phase hein
de concertation puisque cette
concertation elle date déjà de depuis le
début de 2021 elle a déjà 2 ans hein
nous avons déjà 2 ans de recul avec près
de 1200 participations d'habitants de la
ville et des villesalentours d'ailleurs
hein parce qu'on a aussi des des
habitants des villes alentours on passe
à une phase nouvelle euh très concrète
autour des mobilités hein donc de ce
qu'on appelle le le plegare hein qui est
notamment en qui sera en gestion de de
5501 en Yveline avec l'ensemble des
mobilités douce active alors le vélo le
le les les circulations piétonnes bien
évidemment les trottinettes et puis et
surtout peut-être les bus aussi hein
puisque nous aurons une gare routière à
proximité de cette gare du métro donc
c'est cette nouvelle phase qui va
débuter durant l'année 2024 encore une
fois en faisant appel aux participations
des habitants et au niveau des
équipements publics également euh
qu'est-ce qui est prévu alors on a on a
on a un certain nombre de choses
certaines voilà et notamment d'un groupe
scolaire hein d'une taille assez
raisonnable voilà puisque il devrait
avoir une dizaine de classes hein quand
je parle de groupe scolaire c'est bien
maternelle plus élémentaire donc en gros
une dizaine de classes mais aussi une
une crèche hein au niveau de la petite
enfance c'est bien normal et puis un
certain nombre d'équipements du type
salle polyvalente qui peuvent continuer
à accueillir à la fois nos grands
événements mais aussi les association
sportive ou autrre alors cette année
vous lancez également un nouveau
dispositif il s'agit d'un nouveau
portail pour simplifier les démarches en
ligne des habitants qu'est-ce que c'est
concrètement alors mes démarches en
ligne puisque tel est son nom hein de ce
nouveau dispositif il permet simplement
c'est assez simple à comprendre hein
c'est c'est facilitateur pour nos
administrés ça permet de regrouper un
certain nombre de demandes sur dans une
même démarche voilà l'idée c'est
d'aboutir d'ici quelques années à ce que
l'on appelle un guichet unique hein pour
faire simple comme on peut en voir
d'ailleurs dans dans d'autres villes
c'est-à-dire une facilitation des
démarches quel qu'ell soi qu'elle relève
de l'état civil mais aussi des
inscriptions dans les dans les diverses
services de la ville c'était une demande
des habitants oui parce que de plus en
plus cette dématérialisation elle est de
plus en plus importante mais j'alerte
toujours et je le dis toujours et je
vais le faire encore aujourd'hui
n'oublions pas que derrière cette
dématérialisation il y a des gens qui
travaillent voilà alors dans les projets
pour 2024 également François Morton il y
a également la mise en place d'une
mosquée qui est portée par l'Union des
musulmans de guillancour est-ce que un
lieu a déjà été trouvé oui alors et
c'est parfaitement public hein puisque
j'ai eu l'occasion de faire notamment il
y a quelques temps une réunion publique
à ce sujet oui le lieu a été déterminé
après un certain nombre d'études très
très complètes hein pour essayer de
trouver la localisation la plus
pertinente avec un certain nombre de
critères notamment du stationnement des
circulations mais aussi le fait que il
fallait trouver le terrain qui
appartenait à la ville et donc nous
l'avons trouvé ser alors ce sera euh euh
euh pour ceux qui pour être tout à fait
précis c'est donc sur les terres de la
ce qu'on appelle la petite minière hein
en allant vers les jardins familiaux les
le centre de tennis des Trois
Mousquetaires voilà du côté de la du de
de ce qu'on appelle la margearie voilà
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
vous tient également à cœur vous
prévoyez de mettre en place un plan de
49 actions en 2024 c'est-à-dire alors
euh il faut recontextualiser euh cette
question la ville de guyancour a
toujours été engagée sur cette question
de l'égalité femm homme par mes
prédécesseurs par moi-même nous y tenons
c'est important pour nous euh et puis
j'ai eu l'occasion il y a 1 an et demi 2
ans 2 ans et demi maintenant pardon un
peu plus de 2 ans de signer d'être
signataire donc c'était une volonté de
la Ville la Charte européenne pour
l'égalité femm homme donc c'est bien à
l'échelon européen que ça se situe et ça
nous engage pourquoi ça nous engage
parce que dans les 2 ans nous devons
produire un plan d'action et c'est ce
que nous avonsit fait puisque nous
l'avons présenté au dernier conseil
municipal il a été visé et adopté par
l'ensemble du conseil municipal à
l'unanimité avec 49 actions vous avez
raison de le dire avec un recensement
d'actions déjà existantes et de
nouvelles actions parmi ces nouvelles
actions je n'en citerai qu'une parce que
elle me tient à cœur et elle est très
importante c'est la création d'un
nouveau congé menstruel pour nos agentes
et enfin en 2024 François Morton il y a
évidemment les Jeux olympiques de Paris
2024 il va y avoir les épreuves de golf
notamment au Golf National de Guill
encour est-ce que tout est prêt euh non
et c'est bien normal non non non
notamment notamment parce que nous avons
beaucoup de partenaires he sur cette
question alors je rappelle toujours les
dates c'est important que vos vos vos
spectateurs le sachent les épreuves
masculines de golf auront lieu du 1er au
4 août et les épreuves féminines du 7 au
10 donc c'est une grosse dizaine de
jours qui va être concerné par les
épreuves de golf sur le Golf National à
gu en cours euh nonous nous travaillons
encore évidemment avec les services de
l'État avec ceux de cquanttin en Yveline
aussi qui a de de lourdes
responsabilités et j'y suis évidemment
associé en tant que vice-président euh
sur sur l'organisation maintenant nous
avons été rodés il y a quelques années
avec au travers de la rider Cup hein
pour pour ces épreuves de golf et on
sait que a priori le public pourrait
probablement être moindre pour les Jeux
Olympiques que pour la rider Cup de
l'époque donc on a quand même un vécu
sur ce golf nation qui qui fait qu'on
est quand même assez confiant mais tout
sera prêt au moment des g ou évidemment
il y aura pas de et et je rassure nos
habitants il n'y aura pas d'énormes
problèmes de circulation tout est prévu
alors pour terminer cet entretien
François Morton on vous laisse une carte
blanche d'un peu moins d'une minute vous
pouvez aborder le sujet de votre choix
alors un projet pour cette année 2024
qui nous tient à cœur aussi et qui est
lié notamment à l'arrivée du nouveau
quartier hein puisque ce nouveau
quartier on est déjà dans cette question
là mais il va se développer durant la
décennie qui vient et je souhaite
associer l'ensemble des habitants mais
aussi l'ensemble des élus municipaux
quel que soit leur sensibilité
d'ailleurs à un grand projet de
territoire pour la ville de Guy encour
donc on va se faire accompagné par un
cabinet spécialisé durant toute l'année
2024 pour imaginer ensemble le Guy en
cours de 2040 voilà et donc je souhaite
que le maximum d'habitants soi avec nous
dans dans cette réflexion on le
ponctuera d'un nombre de d'événements
festifs fédérateurs durant toute l'année
voilà donc on est très fier et très
heureux de se lancer dans ce projet une
vision sur le long terme sur le long
terme merci beaucoup François Morton
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
excellente année 2024 encci aussi
meilleur vu à toute l'équipe merci
beaucoup c'est la fin de ce 78 merci
pour votre fidélité je vous souhaite une
belle soirée sur tv78 prenez soin de
vous
[Musique]